Robin China season 2 not happening like
walls up no et has learned it's because
the couple has split a source close to
Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna tells ET
quote they are doing the best they can
to stay civil and to co-parent dream the
best they can our source adds the two
are living separately and have worked
out an informal custody agreement over
their daughter quote there forever
connected by that beautiful girl so
there can't be any bad blood according
to our source Robin China are not
filming season two of their reality show
because there isn't anything to film so
II decided to not shoot a second season
on Wednesday the network told ET in a
statement we are continuing to shoot
with all the family members and are
covering Rob and his relationship with
China still ET source says dream has
kept Rob from falling back into a deep
depression quote this breakup would have
sent Rob into a really dark spot but
ever since dream was born he's so
dedicated to getting his life on track
because of her
you